one person I guess who isn't going to be
you know going round perhaps as quickly
as some is the oldest marathon runner
who is John Starbuck who is 87 and joins
us from Staines mr. Starbuck a very good
morning to you and hats off to you for
doing that
why do you want to run a marathon at the
age of 87 I just thought I'd like to run
it and do it for eight UK if I've done
it for several years for them and I
enjoy doing it because it keeps me a bit
fit and everything you know keeps me
remind going they'd be sitting about
indoors too much yeah I gotta say be
absolutely honest with you here you
don't look 87 you don't look anywhere
near 87 there's all this exercise
getting kept you younger do you think
yeah I think so I'm just I think I'm a
bit lucky you know I must have good
genes or something but um that's I've
always done always done exercise lots of
swimming and all that when I was younger
and and never any these violent sports
like football in that so I've always
them always kept a bit fit so what do I
do like what well what do the family
make of it because he imagined that some
you know perhaps some members of the
family might say oh it's tight it's time
to put the running shoes away I think
your granddaughter ran it with you once
didn't she yeah she ran it with me when
she was 18 and but she showed me up
cause she did it in three hours fifty
and I did it in about six hours but yes
she's still running but she couldn't
make it this year because she's out
working abroad but yeah yes she enjoys
it but they say you know you don't look
old or you don't look old that but at
the end of the marathon you really feel
you know when you get to that finish
yeah yeah do you know what John oh I
don't know if I'd make it to the finish
you'd beat me I tell you and look we
know it's going to be hot this weekend
and
yeah how worrying is is that you're
gonna take your time because of the
weather
no I prefer it warm like that I don't
like running in the cold and that's that
that's half the problem with the winter
training it's always cold and I I do get
a bit cold I suppose I mean blood
possibly getting a bit thin now so but
I'd like it about 20 degrees I think
that's better because you can always
cool down for a bit water over yourself
but if you're cold you can't get warm
that's the problem
yeah I'm really looking forward to our
hope on do better than I did before
being warmer can you tell me that bit
about about your good lady wife John
because again some people may think
she's sat at home thinking oh I wish he
wasn't doing it but she's actually
you've got a younger lady haven't you
yeah yeah yeah I've got a bit of a toy
girl yeah she's 79 but Celia always
played netball up right up to she was
about 70 and she's packed it up now
because she damaged their ankle or
something but yeah she just says oh he's
on his own cloud you know let him do it
and that's it she just supports me with
that make sure I eat the right food and
and all that sort of stuff so that's
good and then she'll be out there
watching it I'll bet you it tell us a
little bit about Trudy your daughter
she's got she's got something lined up
for you at the finish line hasn't she
sorry your daughter Trudy what's she
going to do at the finish I wish it
should be at the finish with the
granddaughter me grandson
they're all albeit the finish there and
and they I don't know what they're up to
they don't usually say much but he just
get always comes as a surprise what they
get up to so I just have to be careful
you know yeah I know what they're gonna
get up to I hear they're gonna be stood
by with a walking stick for you yeah how
do they do that or or a Zimmer frame
yeah okay let's go and got a made up for
Zimmer frame and but but I think you
need it when you come out of there
because just getting down off the curbs
you know that hurts so that's what I've
got on the t-shirt ouch that's my name
this year I know you've got I know
you've got a grandson who wants to run
with you at some point is a is a bit
young at the minute so you're gonna have
to have by my calculations when he's 18
you're going to be around 92 or so i
he's still going to do it 92 well I did
say to him you're going to do the
marathon with me when you're 18 and he
just said no I'm not yeah I think it's
decided he's not going to do it but see
it's it does a bit of running at school
and that he's quite good but he it
prefers all the little short Sprint's
you know yeah he's not very keen on the
long long runs yet but he's very young
he's only just coming up for 13 so if
you've got time to talk him round John
can I just say that you are you are
you're an inspiration to us all the very
best of luck to you yeah I hope yeah I
hope you have a great run on Sunday yeah
yeah I will do I do we best anyway just
keep going and take it steady yeah quite
right too slow and steady John thank you
very much indeed that's it thank you
very much yeah